Pech I really tough shot these wood
boxes word and still that's what gives
Lee's been doing he hasn't taken a lot
of jump shots he can put his head down
and getting great to the ramp in all of
us we got all the good plate he's was
pretty good just olive oil this is the
fantastic person should've shot that one
he was greater into the basket and tried
making the path when shooting was his
best outfit as you see peasley coming
down and again as I said earlier the
first half
[Applause]
[Music]
as these links on the hops of whiskey's
and right back
leave Beasley a little
michael beasley fight gear right pizza
again michael beasley second three of
the night looking for bio a state of
failure back
[Applause]
easily went on fire Beasley spinning
Michael Beasley now they say a cheer we
had a foot off the line they can add to
that lead healthy pigeon attacks of the
rim the service stands for Beasley
taking advantage
[Music]
[Applause]
fourth water here at Madison Square
Garden but it's down lead it 89-81
overpass hit they add to that lead on
the bucket by Michael these gents
porzingis shot clock out of five he
pulls it up
[Applause]
for these were